dominique anglade chef du parti libéral
du québec nous allons donc hier après
l'entrevue que le premier ministre
faire des entrevues à tous les jours
avec les chefs des partis principaux à
québec madame anglade bonsoir bonsoir
sur la pandémie
monsieur legault zeyer jongle avec
l'idée d'une commission technique un peu
à la manière de la commission nicolet
après les inondations à ce que selon
vous ce serait en effet un bon moyen
pour faire la lumière sur le drame en
trop des sièges celle des ça pourrait
l'être en notant que l'on considère
l'ensemble de ce qui s'est passé vous
savez déjà la semaine dernière je pose à
une série de questions à françois
legault par rapport par rapport à la
pandémie
pourquoi la cellule de crise avait été
mise en place si tard quels avaient été
les indications qu'on avait de la santé
publique depuis le mois de janvier
je pense qu'une série de questions
auxquelles il faut trouver réponses
surtout dans une optique où on va on va
rentrer en septembre avec la rentrée des
classes
il faut s'assurer d'être d'être prêt
d'être prêt pour une deuxième vague de
bien comprendre la manière dont le
gouvernement réfléchit à tout ça je
pense qu'on a besoin d'avoir des
réponses à ces questions parce que vous
vous estimez que ils sont arrivés trop
tard dans un mode de crise mais écoutez
ce qui est clair c'est que déjà avant le
au mois de janvier le docteur arruda
avait déjà mentionné qu'il y avait des
enjeux par rapport à la coved
on s'était levé en commission n'avait
posé des questions février on se rend
compte que c'est très tard finalement
que les équipements la protection a été
a été commandé par la ministre à cannes
je pense qu à une série de questions
qu'il faut obtenir réponse alors le
moyen ça peut très bien être la
commission ça peut être d'autre moyen
également mais il est très important
pour nous de se préparer aussi pour la
suite des choses pour que l'on soit
organisée et structurée de la
protectrice du citoyen aussi qui va
lancer une enquête
c'est intéressant on verra jusqu'où elle
est ce qu'elle arrête tout les tous les
éléments pour répondre à ces questions
là bas l'autre gros débat ça a été à la
fin de la session ça a été le projet de
loi 61
oui il hier monsieur legault nous disait
regardez leur m
à montréal le gouvernement libéral a
donné a permis à la caisse de contourner
certaines procédures d'expropriation par
exemple pour que ce projet se développe
rapidement ce que ces poissons un peu
l'esprit du projet de loi 61 je pense
qu'il faut faire très attention parce
que le rem c'est un projet on parle de
202 projets qui étaient très spécifique
ses potes c'est plein de règles qui ont
été contournés dans ce projet là c'était
très circonscrit par le projet de loi 61
la raison pour laquelle ça a fait
l'unanimité
on a eu une unanimité contre le projet
de loi que ce soit la protectrice du
citoyen que ce soit le comité de suivi
de la commission charbonneau que ce soit
le barreau du québec les groupes
environnementaux c'est que le
gouvernement voulait s'approprier des
pouvoirs pendant une période de temps
indéterminée on parlait de deux ans
initialement alors qu'ils avait aucune
raison de s'approprier tous ses pouvoirs
là alors je pense que c'est surtout ça
c'est qu'ils sont arrivés avec un projet
de loi qui était qui était brouillon ils
n'ont pas su expliquer la raison la
nécessité de le faire d'autant plus que
c'était pas un projet de loi qui est un
projet de l'europe doit de relance
économique mais vraiment un projet de
loi ceux des infrastructures c'est une
partie de la relance mais ce n'est
certainement pas tout la relance
économique
est-ce qu'il en manquait beaucoup dans
les amendements pour avoir l'appui du
parti libéral inscrit il aurait fallu de
beaucoup d'amendements encore ou de
quelques phrases ici et là mais il y
aurait fallu que la liste des
amendements qu'on voulait retirer et été
retirés puis je vous dirais que si on
avait vraiment voulu avancer d'un point
de vue strictement économique pour les
restaurateurs pour les détaillants pour
les personnes de la construction pour
qu'ils soient payés plus rapidement
on aurait pu s'entendre sur certains
éléments à passer rapidement d'un point
de vue économique et les si la notion d
infrastructures pour plus tard
malheureusement le gouvernement a peu
voulu le faire est une des raisons pour
celle là je pense que c'est parce qu'on
voulait encore se garder des pouvoirs
qui n'était pas essentielle et on s'est
retrouvé dans cette situation là moi je
suis encore et les jetons encore la main
au gouvernement pour que les éléments
strictement et
nick pour nos petites entreprises dans
toutes les régions du québec on puisse
les passer à pendant l'été bon alors on
verra pas ce qu'ils voient revenir à la
charge il l'a dit publiquement monsieur
le premier
ils vont revenir à la charge à la
session d'automne ben écoute et j'espère
que l'été va être un bon moment de
réflexion pour le gouvernement et qu'ils
amèneront les amendements les
amendements nécessaires
ce qui est évident c'est que tout le
monde veut qu'on aille de l'avant avec
une relance économique ça peut faire
partie de cette relance économique parce
que les mères effectivement ont fait
pression pour le projet de loi 71 c'est
peut-être le seul groupe clairement pour
le projet de loi parce que beaucoup de
gens disent ah quand même pas de bon
sens que ça prenne trois ans pour faire
un parc un des ces jeunes que ça prenne
4 ans pour faire monsieur legault parlé
ce matin en bourse d'un autre exempt
c'est vrai que c'est là alors ça cela
vous avez raison là dessus c'est vrai
que c'est lent à différents à différents
endroits et la protectrice du citoyen et
venir dire exactement la même chose
c'est beaucoup trop lent mais pour
régler le problème ce n'est pas
contourner les lois pour régler le
problème c'est d'ajouter spécifiquement
des ressources pour accélérer les
processus
on l'a vu par exemple en matière
environnementale quand on a été capable
d'ajouter des ressources pour étudier
des projets on a été capable d'accélérer
les choses
donc il faut régler le problème plutôt
que d'essayer de contourner le message
ne pouvait pas être plus clair de la
part de la part des instances qui sont
venus nous voir en commission
parlementaire
donc on est dernier sur le problème pas
nécessairement sur la manière de régler
madame en garde le comité sur le racisme
qui a été créée hier donc vos réactions
à ce que vous êtes vous donner la chance
au coureur vous êtes jeu
voyons voir ce qu'ils vont proposer je
pense qu'il faut absolument donner
donner la chance au gouvernement de
pouvoir poser des actions concrètes
ils ont mis leur comité en place ils ont
dit qu'ils allaient avoir une obligation
de résultat
vous voyez tout ce qui se passe dans le
monde depuis la nécessité pour le québec
aussi de se positionner sur cet enjeu là
donc effectivement moi j'attends
j'attends impatiemment les là ce qui va
sortir de tout ça je vous dirais
également que nous on a offert notre
collaboration gouvernement par rapport
au comité qui l'ont mis en place alors
s'ils ont besoin de d'experts s'ils ont
besoin de commentaires ou de
propositions on répondra certainement
présents c'est un enjeu qui doit être
très largement trans partisan l'a
d'ailleurs j'aurais pu demander qui est
un député libéral qui un député péquiste
il n'avait pu agrandir le cercle c'est
un exemple de ça c'est la commission la
commission laurent où tout le monde a
été impliqué là dedans ils ont décidé de
fonctionner autrement c'est leur choix
c'est leur prérogative également mais
encore une fois je pense que ce qui va
être important dans cet enjeu la seule
obligation de résultat ce qui va ce qui
va en découler et on attendra donc ok
rapidement votre cabinet fantôme bon
c'est peut-être des chinoiseries pour
les gens mais quand même c'est important
parce que vous placez les gens andré
fortin leader parlementaire
gaétan barrette qui perd le conseil du
trésor parce que c'est une des motions
pourquoi pas du tout et chaque année il
fait en fait
gaétan barrette va s'occuper de deux
dossiers importants autant que sont les
infrastructures dans un premier temps et
les infrastructures et toute l'autorité
des marchés financiers marchés publics
est également le dossier de
l'immigration qui est un dossier que je
portais moi même à une époque qui qui
sont des dossiers qui sont essentiels et
l'éducation
marc va risquer l'éducation ce trésor et
le conseil du trésor
vous avez carlos leitao qui prend les
clés de l'économie et les changements
climatiques je pense que d'un point de
vue message de modernité on l'envoie le
message très clair sur l'importance de
combiner économie changement climatique
francs dit benjamin avec environnement
et jeunesse je pense qu'on est en train
de faire la démonstration avec le
cabinet qu'on amène de la volonté de
moderniser la grande vision libérale de
me les corps glabre chef du parti
libéral du québec merci a bientot moi
qui vous remercie